[Musique]
je peux pas voir ça les décollages
atterrissages je peux marcher trop le
vertige par contre après quand c'est con
c'est net
je suis là ml j'ai perdu du temps de
tourner sur toi même
vous savez en tant que pilote j'ai quand
même parcouru plus de 400 pays j'ai fait
plus de huit continent marque à 7
continents 8 continue éric l'amérique
[Musique]
hockey dans quelques instants vous le
savez l'une d'entre vous va devoir
quitter la villa dans la vie n'a dans la
villa dans la ville on savait maintenant
la villa dans la villa et en direction
de son domicile
ben ça c'est pour chacune d'entre vous
c'est différent
ces revues mais vous ne l'ignorez pas
cette soirée est loin d'être terminée
dans quelques instants
l'une d'entre vous va devoir quitter
l'aventuré première nouvelle alors là tu
grand n'importe quoi
j'ai toujours et la tunisie la tunisie
ce prochain billet c'est la production
qui me l'a dit petit ans que j'étais il
les traits c'est un mot italien qui veut
dire homme de lettres ouais d'accord qui
en italien veut dire obtenait une vie et
non pas un vie sont dit que j'étais
totalement il est
les filles j'ai une petite charrette
pour vous qu'est ce qui rime
non non non non j'ai toujours cette peur
de ne pas mériter l'amour joue le groupe
et ça se fait beaucoup
je veux comprendre un peu quand même
le dernier mardi à la vérité est là et
bien une idée mais en fait pas très bien
aimé des prêts mais ma vie ce n'est pas
que des rires c'est aussi parfois des
pleurs encore trop tard alexandre
beaucoup trop tard qu'elle très mauvaise
expérience vous arrivez à pleurer avec
les larmes et tous et les mêmes vieux
fayyad est en eux mêmes mais geste
j'arrive à plus rien contrôler tu
mérites et de l'aimer midi dim avec la
voix de kristen bell dans batman on y va
un dernier coup en elie semoun va pas
très bien
c'est lui qui m'a appris ça mais bon moi
je quitte ce programme puisse l'accepter
tu voulais d'abord je prêche convient
[Rires]
l'accepter donc je dois enchaîner après
je joue bien non c'est non non non tu es
ici pour recevoir ses bas c'est pour
perdre une et skoda pardon je commence à
me faire du coup jamais ça arrive ça
arrive même aux meilleurs
freud prennent assez fred ses frais de
choix je prononce routes depuis le début
[Rires]
emilie ml - tu as été malhonnête
malodorantes et malvoyantes
mais j'ai les yeux et la plus nulle
devra coucher avec moi qui a le bras
dans le sud marc attend
[Musique]
c'est très bien qu'est ce qu'on fait
maintenant je sais pas mais non alors
que moi alors que moi alors comment je
sais rien je ne savais pas où j'allais
la première fois le deuxième billet pour
marc airlines la prochaine personne
appartient avec moi à bord de marque
airlines marque il faut valérie partante
elle vient de péter vaudry effectué à
péter mais vous avez pété marque
valérie vient de péter ça pue qu'elle
porte
irrespirable c'est fou je ris mais c'est
de le rester
mark valley vient de péter ça puis il
faut qu'elle parte et besoin de 2 dead
parce que clairement je me dis que je
aux nations pour ça non mais
marc tabac marque ça va ça va ma vallée
vient de péter sa fille qu'elle parte
quoi il faut répéter ça excusez moi ça
vous fait de pires de ma ghadir pas
d'excusés mois marc valérie vient de
péter ça puis il faut qu'elle soit
[Rires]
petite merde au pas chier et tangue en
bas des petites [ __ ] versailles
fraude
fred va chier au beaucoup s'il vous
plaît qu'à la paix que la personne que
la personne qui vient de péter que la
personne qui vient de péter ce qu'est ce
qu'on pense de cette séance ce bilan
j'ai pas aimé